an animated short film is one that
employs no live actors only animated
ones who are of course represented by
animated agents an animated short film
and not run over 30 minutes and neither
should we
the nominees are charade John minutes
producer dr. de Soto Morton Shingo and
Michael's foreign producers paradise
mushy Patel producer and the winner is
the winner is sure a John minutes
producer
I found myself in a wonderful position
this is the second acceptance speech
I've given in the last weekend and
that's unbelievable then I try not to
repeat the first speech I made it with
the exception of thanking and Sando for
her support during not only during the
making of this film but for her support
during my career change so it was when I
was a lad in Birmingham England my
mother used to deliberately take me out
of school to go and see a picture with
her on a Wednesday afternoon and I think
it was more for company than for size
but I'd like to say hello to my mother
back in England and my sister Mary and
briefly I'd like to say thanks to
telefilm Michael Mills for getting the
film down here and the Academy thank you
for best achievement in live-action
short films the ones that use live
actors with hopefully live agents the
nominees those producers who gave us
three good things in very small packages
are the painted door Michael Macmillan
and Janis L flat producers tales of
meeting and parting sharon auric and
leslie linka glare producers up Mike
Hoover producer winner is up Mike Hoover
producer
this took seven years to make and there
were quite a few people that stuck with
us thank you
Lynn and Dave Adams Edie Caesar and a
special thanks to Timothy Wade Huntley
thank you